all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are back with the umbrella
academy now here's one of the things
that we're we're going to cover here and
it's not a great big huge thing it's
kind of a small momentary thing but it
is designed to illustrate how powerful
rumor is because as you guys know in the
netflix series when you see rumors
always like i heard a rumor and then
usually it involves a power that's
really similar to the purple man zebedee
kilgrave in the sense that she can get
people to do the things that she wants
in the comics she's way more powerful
than that but you don't see it very
often and that is one of the things to
sort of explain here right to preface
here is that gerard way does present the
different members of the umbrella
academy as being exceedingly powerful if
this comic took place in the marvel
universe you'd be looking at characters
with universal levels of power but the
reality is that the way gerard way wrote
it is that because it's more of a dark
humor type story the powers despite the
fact that they can do incredible things
are largely used on a smaller scale and
for the most part scaled down and so the
reason why i say this is that what this
does is it initially opens up
essentially with the statue of abraham
lincoln just wreaking havoc on
washington dc
and basically attacking everything like
literally pogo just has like sticks of
dynamite because remember this happens
uh quite some time ago about 17 years
ago so they're still little kids so pogo
hasn't necessarily died yet you still do
have been here so again ben hasn't
necessarily died yet again he died
sometime between 17 years ago and the
current moment but the thing behind this
is that with the statue just kind of
going nuts and just basically attacking
everybody but the umbrella academy is
basically trying to corral everybody in
trying to stay organized and structured
because remember they're not really
given a whole lot of direction by
reginald hargreaves right they're kind
of taught to operate as a team to a
degree but it's not really the same kind
of tutelage that you're used to seeing
with like the x-men what you end up
getting though is you have rumor that
basically fixes everything and that's
when she she literally tells the
president tells the statue i heard a
rumor that you were assassinated and so
what you end up having is her just
manifesting a statue of what's basically
john wilkes booth kicking out president
lincoln
literally just shouting sick temper
taranis right it's just kind of nuts i
mean it's essentially the same thing he
yelled after the assassination of
lincoln but still it's one of those
things where she kind of manifests
something into existence and then at
that point the statute just basically
runs off we don't really find out what
happens to it but it basically takes
away but that's the thing about about
rumor right she's incredibly powerful
nine times out of ten her power is used
in a more confined space which is
getting people to do things but she does
have the ability to alter reality with
her powers i mean imagine that well you
had a character in marvel comics i heard
a rumor that i have the infinity stones
suddenly the infinity gauntlets in her
hand that's the kind of thing that
you're talking about here so it is a
pretty high level of power but you don't
really see it used that often now at
that point we kind of jump through and
we're gonna we're gonna fast track this
but you kind of jump through what the
different characters are doing in the
aftermath of volume one in the
apocalypse suite so the acceptance that
reginald hargreaves is dead the fact
that they saved the world and everything
that had gone on uh for luther himself
he's basically just morbidly obese
having fallen and fallen into a state of
depression he literally just sits around
watching tv shows all day long and just
eating cookies that's basically it the
seance is is considered pretty famous
now right because he's the one that
basically saved the world from like the
meteor crashing into it so he's done
that much which is pretty awesome kind
of enjoying his fame not getting too
carried away with it but enough where
it's kind of gone to his head and he
sees himself as is somewhat of a big
deal uh you do have yanya who of course
now is referred to as the white violin
that's kind of her thing but she doesn't
really remember anything that had
happened and she can't move you do have
uh you do have rumor that holds a bit of
a grudge against her at least that seems
to be the case and in fact in this
instance when you have rumor approaching
yanu that you basically have rumor who
takes her away literally whisks her off
even though white violin doesn't
remember who rumor is and then rumor
sits her in front of a whole bunch of
monitors where she's forced to just
watch everything that she had done uh
when she had essentially turned into a
villain rumor herself of course doesn't
have the ability to use her voice right
of course again her throat was cut and
uh in the last volume so you know
towards the end of that she can't really
talk as much and then you have diego
right you basically have kraken who's
going through and trying to find out
what's going on with the the murders
inside the diner because if you guys
recall from volume one while we didn't
necessarily cover it in depth it wasn't
really relevant at that point in time it
is here what had happened is there was a
meeting but there was a kind of
conversation that took place between
pogo and number five where they had gone
to a diner and that in the midst of that
you just kind of saw these guys come out
of nowhere with no explanation as to who
they were and they just started
attacking uh number five and pogo and
then they were swiftly dealt with off
panel so it was kind of like this just
quick little one or two page thing that
went on i left it out because i felt
like it would have been just a little
too much information given everything
that was going on in the first volume uh
but that was it right this was basically
kraken following up that lead and this
journey initially started in the last
volume but it's kind of continuing on
here that whole situation will be a huge
point of conversation here in this story
hence the reason why we're focusing so
much on it uh but it's literally just
diego trying to find out what was going
on in the diner and trying to understand
everything that's taking place there now
again what you end up doing of course is
picking up with number five who's
essentially betting the horses
that's kind of his thing of course as he
leaves the the racetrack or gets out to
the parking lot suddenly you have him
surrounded by all these different guys
right all these different agents they're
kind of these wonky space-age looking
dudes and of course he overcomes every
single one of them with what's basically
the greatest of ease and the question
that has to be asked here is how is he
able to overcome every single one of
these guys and a lot of you guys are
probably drawing on the tv show where
you're like well i mean you know he's a
trained assassin and he is what happens
here is a little bit different slightly
modified although not deeply not
intensely based on what you saw in the
show it's pretty similar in that way but
he overcomes every single one of these
guys right now one of the things that i
do want to point out here is that in the
show you got like like hazel and cha-cha
here it's a whole different beast they
exist but they're totally different
[Laughter]
from the characters in the tv show and i
would say they're actually better in the
comic than they are in the show but in
effect he takes all these guys out right
all these guys are defeated and that's
when you end up having one of them who's
kind of a survivor and is like okay uh
literally radios into headquarters and
is like we're all taken out right we're
all basically dead we need
reinforcements you need to send in hazel
and cha-cha and as soon as number five
hears that he start like he literally
just experiences this massive amount of
dread because he's like we're already
dead like they're gonna kill us all like
hazel and cha-cha are no laughing matter
right they are not a joke at all and so
that's where you pick up with these two
now we're not really given any
information about how they arrived here
although again you know time travel
shenanigans and whatnot they just appear
here but they're basically at this diner
right the same diner where you had
everything that went down with uh with
number five and pogo when they killed
all those different agents and hazel and
chacha as they're depicted here one
thing that i want to point out you never
actually see their faces here instead
they just wear these giant cartoonish
mask helmet things and that's basically
it now we are going to be giving some
information about them although we're
not going to go into a deep dive about
them because we don't get it right it's
really one of those things where like we
get a kind of description of them and
it's really more the the context and the
things they do that explain what they're
about more so than any backstory that we
would get but what goes on here is they
talk about how delicious the pie is and
they're like what's in this thing and
ultimately the chef comes out and he was
like you know we can't tell you like i'm
not going to tell you anything in fact
there was a guy that came here from
barcelona and offered me five grand for
and i told him man you have to cover you
know cut off my arms and legs in order
to get that whole thing out of me so
again at that point uh that's basically
what they do hazel and cha-cha cut off
this guy's arms and legs in order to get
the secret of what's in that pie that's
how twisted these guys are i bet you
didn't see that in the show
[Laughter]
that's how messed up these dudes are now
while they're doing that of course
they're basically contacted by
headquarters which is like don't forget
your mission you're here to find the kit
and that's literally when they're like
oh yeah i forgot okay so um did any any
of you guys remember like a little kid
that was there uh he basically acted
like an adult do you have any memory of
that or anything you know just while
your arms and legs are gone
it's kind of crazy but what the guy
basically says is they use canned apples
it's like the only thing he says right
like we use canned apples and so it's
kind of nuts of course the the waitress
is just kind of made to watch the entire
thing go down but like they literally
cut this dude's arms and legs off with a
saw so that's why it's kind of wild man
it's pretty extreme that's why i say
there's a very dark humor when it comes
to umbrella academy it's in a lot of
ways very different from the netflix
show as you saw it now one of the things
that goes on here is you basically pick
up with kraken in the office of
detective lupo remember lupo being the
guy who's basically watching everything
and kind of going through this
investigation with number five for the
most part we know that kraken basically
provides information to lupo lupo
provides information to kraken they have
that kind of batman jim gordon
relationship going on but they don't
divulge everything and they still do
kind of keep things from each other to a
degree all this really comes to a head
when kraken looks over all the
information both from the entire
massacre that happened out of the race
track as well as the whole thing that
happened in the diner putting two and
two together he realizes whoever it was
that did this did it with surgical
precision they knew what they were doing
they were an exceedingly capable
assassin and so it's kind of on the
trail of it basically being number five
lupo kind of hinted the idea that he
knows this number five or believes his
number five but kraken of course figures
it out right off the bat that he
essentially knows that it's him but
ultimately neither one really comes
clean with their findings and so as a
result of that you really just kind of
have kraken going about kind of clearing
his head traveling back to the house and
you don't really get a whole lot going
on here it's really more of him just
kind of chastising uh what is an effect
luther for just being overweight and
having depression and stuff like that
literally he yells at him for having it
right but at the end of the day of
course it's uh just kind of designed to
show the essential breakdown of the
family dynamics of the umbrella academy
that even working together to save the
world there was seemingly no real way to
unify them together and so what you end
up doing of course with number five
basically you know mia that rumor is the
one that figures out where he is by just
a little artifact that he left in his
room back at the house and so by tracing
it down she basically finds number five
and probably one of the weirdest moments
in all of comics where number five is
paying a chimp dresses marilyn monroe
singing happy birthday to you mr
president in a hotel room so you know
hey in in new york city you can get
anything you want if you have enough
money
if you have the money to pay for it you
can get it right that's basically what
that is so again a lot of stuff kind of
happens in a really fast period of time
for example you basically have hazel and
chacha that end up catching up to seance
of course they knock him unconscious and
then essentially kidnap him all for the
purpose of trying to find the
information of where number five is
right just kind of going through each
member of the family now of course as
you guys may have known just from your
your time in reading umbrella academy or
even just from the show that seance just
can't really use his powers when he has
shoes on just one of those weird little
caveats so he kind of makes the joke to
have his shoes removed of course they
ultimately say no but what ends up going
on is that while you have hazel and
cha-cha that leave momentarily the
waitress takes off the shoes of seance
and when that happens he actually enters
into a tv tries to communicate with
luther tell luther he's being kidnapped
luther's got to save him and then of
course luther barely wakes up at the
tail end of that not really sure if it's
a dream or not the other part of this is
that a deal had previously been worked
out at the very beginning of the story
back in in you know in the 1960s back
about 17 years later where essentially
in order for the umbrella academy to
save washington dc from the statue of
abraham lincoln that had gone awry that
a bargain was struck between reginald
hargreaves and president kennedy the
kennedy would hand over nukes to
reginald hargreaves those nukes never
seemed to have been used but they're
discovered by hazel and cha-cha and so
what ends up going on is that hazel and
cha-cha actually bring the nukes in with
the intention of essentially detonating
them right with literally going like
setting them off and basically
destroying the world kind of this idea
if they can't find number five
they'll just blow up the world and
they'll call it a day right just that's
that's kind of the extent and the
insanity to which these guys will go in
order to achieve their goal and so what
you end up doing is switching over to
this bit of an explanation that number
five gives to rumor where rumor
literally tells him i want to know
everything and he effectively spills the
beans and what he says is that when he
was stuck in the future and started
transitioning back to the past along the
way he'd basically been been taken right
he'd been caught by what is in effect
gerard way's a variation of the time
variance authority right just an
organization that exists out there
they're mostly referred to as the temps
atronalis so basically an organization
that exists in order to ensure the time
stream isn't disrupted people don't
cause variations in the time stream and
things progress as they're supposed to
one of the first things that happened is
the body of number five was essentially
modified to basically make him the best
killer possible and the way this was
done was by quite literally taking
personality traits to a degree or
capabilities of every great assassin
across the timeline and putting them
inside him and that's how he became so
capable is because he's basically the
best assassin in existence because he's
every assassin in existence combined
into one and what he talks about is that
there are a lot of people that are part
of this organization that have been
brought in from various circumstances
and they all basically say this uh serve
the same role when it comes to hazel and
cha-cha then of course number five is
better than them but these guys are nuts
you know they're literally just crazy
serial killer type characters they'll
just do whatever it is they need to do i
executed all kinds of missions for these
guys right they call them corrections
but then eventually they assign me a
mission that i just wouldn't take that
they wanted me to take out kennedy and
so ultimately he was like that was the
moral the moral line that i simply
couldn't cross because of the things he
did and how he changed the country in
such an effective way so he ultimately
went rogue and he's basically been been
hunted by this time authority ever since
and so now that they know where he's at
that's why you have hazel and cha-cha
who were sent here now of course that's
when you end up getting this whole
scenario where you literally have luther
realizing the whole sequence with seance
was not a dream and seance was actually
being kidnapped and he was going to be
killed he finally traces him down gets
to his location but when he gets in
there he's ambushed by hazel and chacha
who of course incapacitate him and so
what you end up getting is this really
really cool moment uh where you have a
couple things that happen at the same
time and again this is where the story
gets kind of wild if it hasn't really
gotten wild already that you basically
have number five who again communicating
his whole story with uh with rumor she
doesn't believe it she doesn't really
believe anything it is that he's saying
and so that's when you have carmichael
who shows up now carmichael is of course
the fish in a fish tank attached to a
body and running the entirety of this
whole organization or at least one of
the people who's running the whole thing
and so when he appears that's when rumor
realizes that's like all of this is
basically true right now the thing about
that is this has to happen the way that
the the the you know tim uh atronalis
says like this has to take place the the
assassination of kennedy has to go down
it simply can't be ignored one it's a
finite point in the time stream and two
if that doesn't take place it's gonna
cause all kinds of issues and so the
results of this is they're like number
five is rogue and he's out there one you
have to stop him to ensure this takes
place and when the initial question is
why would we help you right like what
reason do we have to do this like we
could just say no right like i mean we
could just blow it off what they end up
doing or at least what carmichael does
is he basically reveals that they have
agents that are there with number five's
mom and that they'll pull the trigger on
its mom and the bigger significance of
this is that it's not just number five
who will die it's number five's twin
right he literally has a sibling out
there that we haven't been introduced to
yet or at least seemingly haven't been
introduced to yet so literally he's got
another person out there and so the
result of that is of course with the two
of them kind of being like okay number
five has to exist if he doesn't exist
essentially the world won't be saved
we'll all basically die because there'll
be no one to warn us that the world is
going to come to an end uh okay like
we'll go on this mission because there
are far bigger things at stake here than
just the life of kennedy right that's a
pretty significant thing and so what you
end up doing here is switching over you
know back to hazel and chacha and you
have them doing their whole thing right
kind of with the intention of just being
like you know we should let's just let's
just nuke it all right so what they end
up doing is basically activating the the
nuclear bombs right the nuclear weapons
and then in turn you know of course they
don't necessarily go off immediately
there's a kind of delayed effect with
regards to these things in the middle of
this whole thing one pulls a gun on the
other blows their head off and then
kills himself and that's when you find
out that what had happened is that with
his shoes being removed seance had the
ability to possess one of them and
basically get them both killed and so
following that what you have is them
kind of asking the question like what in
the world comes next right like what do
we what do we do here like what do we do
like quite literally in this whole
situation and they effectively do the
only thing they can do that the missions
kind of go off at the same time that in
this you know time variance
authority-esque place right the temp uh
atronalis headquarters that you have the
mission that's essentially described by
carmichael and saying that number five
will try to prevent the assassination of
kennedy and he'll be in the books book
depository building which is basically
where you know lee harvey oswald was and
that's you know at least depending on
who you talked to was the one who
actually took out kennedy some say he
was never acting alone as that's
probably one of the biggest things out
there right one of the biggest
discussions out there uh it really just
kind of goes both ways but that's where
number five in his old age will be the
job of younger number five and rumor and
the rest of the rest of these guys is to
get out there and stop number five and
ensure the whole thing goes through
right to literally ensure that kennedy
is basically taken out and that's when
younger number five is like okay we can
do that but i have a plan right like
literally you always need a backup plan
i need your best surgeons and so what
you end up doing is jumping directly to
uh to luther along with uh kraken as
well as uh seance and what seance really
does is by going through and digging up
the body of pogo he comes to the
realization that pogo's not there right
pogo's body isn't there that he was
basically buried somewhere else in this
body instead is basically the body of
one of the time traveling agents who
they can use in order to go back in time
and effectively ensure that presumably
kennedy's not taken out right then being
a part of that mission as well and so
that's where things kind of go nuts
because it's just all these different
places all these different locations or
roles that lead to the same place the
funny thing about it is that where
luther asks about like the detonator and
the nuclear weapons the response to sean
says no we're good man like i got it all
taken care of right these guys teleport
away the earth explodes
the earth is destroyed because seance
basically screwed up right none of it
went down the way it was supposed to and
so what you end up doing here is jumping
to all these different routes meeting at
the same place right all these people
meeting at the same location in the
sense of the whole thing in dallas with
kennedy now you do have number five at
least old number five and young number
five along with the forces of the temp
atrion alice who were all just shooting
out right in the book depository
building it's a great big huge shoot out
here at the same time you of course have
the arrival of kraken and seance and uh
and luther who show up here and they're
able to just incapacitate these various
agents actually on the side of older
number five so they kind of intervene in
this capacity and that while you have
everything taking place the one question
of luther is where's rumor and where
number five's like i can't tell you
where she is right it's just a really
really long story luther freaks out and
literally goes to attack young number
five and almost kills him right it's
like i'm gonna take like i'm gonna
destroy you where you are unless you
tell me what i need to know and that's
when younger number five is like
basically there has to be like there had
to be a backup plan and in fact they
kind of work or at least at least older
number five is told go through and do
your thing now he doesn't actually take
out kennedy instead he takes out the
person that was going to take out
kennedy instead what goes on here is in
order to ensure that the death of
kennedy does take place but it's not
number five the older number five who's
the one that has to do it right in order
to have this blood on his hand so
essentially he can maintain his moral
role but at the same time allow the time
stream to stay intact that rumor was
down in the car with kennedy posing as
jackie and remember because she can
alter reality by using her voice she
tells kennedy i heard a rumor that the
back of your head is about to explode
and that's what that's how kennedy dies
it looks like an assassination now the
way this plays out is that it kind of
it's a really funny way that gerard way
does this because one of the big reasons
that a lot of people say that harvey
oswald wasn't acting alone is because
people say that there was another
shooter that when you had the the impact
of the bullets there had to be somebody
on quote unquote the grassy knoll this
basically satisfies that it satisfies
the assassination of kennedy or the
death of kennedy and the fact that
somebody else had to be acting or had to
be involved there because the direction
of the bullets and the impact and all
that kind of stuff just doesn't match up
so in a lot of ways this kind of gerard
way just sort of playing on that idea
that you know again lee harvey oswald
wasn't acting alone but with everything
sort of sorted out right everything
basically kind of arranged and taken
care of that with everybody focusing on
the president once he's rushed to the
hospital but of course presumed dead
what it does is it allows rumor again
posing as jackie kennedy to sort of move
away for a minute because the real
jackie kennedy is actually there and a
lot of people the the initial diagnosis
of the doctor is well obviously she's in
shock that's why she can't remember
everything uh you know once every once
the shock wears off and she comes to
she'll recall the entire event but it's
her mind trying to deal with a very
traumatic experience the truth about it
is that jackie kennedy wasn't there but
it was rumor posing as jackie kennedy by
this point rumors basically pose as a
nurse and then just kind of goes into
what is basically an ambulance occupied
by the rest of the team and then of
course manages to get away with them all
but the crazy thing about this is that
when the questions ask like was it worth
it and is this really what you did to
get your voice back rumor takes it as a
personal affront because while she did
go with the temp atrin alice in order to
get her voice back so she could operate
as part of this whole campaign right
this whole scheme the reality here is
she didn't do it of her own volition she
didn't do it because she just really
wanted her voice back that bad that's
what luther's assumption is she did it
because the reality here is that luther
is the twin of number five he's
basically his biological brother and
that if the mother of number five had
been killed the way that carmichael said
she would that what it would do is it
would essentially lead to the deaths of
both luther and number five she did this
to save the life of luther but at the
end of the day luther i wouldn't go as
far as to say didn't want to hear it but
it does kind of take him by surprise and
it does sort of shock him that that's
sort of the bigger picture going on here
now of course once they arrived back in
the modern day what they were expecting
was just some kind of huge change right
the whole idea of corrections the time
stream maybe it would be some kind of
modern utopia or something like that
when they get back it's all basically
the same there's no real difference here
and so while we would expect the world
to have been destroyed right them
arriving back to a dead world what you
end up having is the arrival of
carmichael and carmichael basically
spills the beans and explains everything
that's going on and what carmichael says
here is that when it comes to the
corrections it's not somehow fixing a
timeline or it's not as though you know
kennedy having gone out the way that he
did would somehow make everything better
that the reality here is the timeline
has to exist in its current form right
kennedy had to be taken out when he did
uh things had to progress from there it
had to go that way and so the result of
this is them just basically ensuring
things work out that the reality is that
the the end of kennedy was supposed to
happen at the hands of number five and
that because number five initially chose
not to other arrangements had to be made
but the point behind this is that with
the rest of the team getting involved
them going back in time all that kind of
stuff that it allowed the timeline to
happen the way that it was supposed to
the arrival of like hazel and cha-cha
right like the nukes going off all that
kind of stuff that was all a result of
the fact that number five initially
refused to take out kennedy right a
cascading effect that because of one
decision that was made that it
essentially created a branch timeline
that they didn't know they were a part
of that resulted in kennedy essentially
surviving right continuing on and living
that because kennedy was taken out those
nukes never got in the hands of reginald
hargreaves which never got to the hands
of hazel and chacha which never ended
the world that kind of a thing right so
everything else basically remains intact
but the world has just essentially
inadvertently been saved or at least was
saved by the the umbrella academy who
didn't know that they were essentially
being used by carmichael and all those
different guys and so realizing that
kind of manipulation was going on behind
the scenes number five the younger
number five freaks destroys the glass
jar housing carmichael and then eats him
just just just as a sheer display of
anger right literally just destroys that
guy just consumes that guy and so
following that again the team basically
disbands they're really just a defunct
like a like just a totally divided
family in a variety of different ways
they just kind of go their own way and
do their own thing that you do have
rumor who goes back to white violin
basically kind of makes amends or the
two of them reconcile to a degree seance
listens to a song on a jukebox at a bar
just things like that right kraken goes
and does his own thing just the their
own kind of breakaway their own kind of
deviation just doing their own thing and
having nothing to do with anything else
so with that being said guys again when
it comes to umbrella academy these
stories are really really wild and it's
the reason why the netflix series toned
it all down so much because i mean we're
doing the finer points here there are
i'm sorry the broad points there are
some finer points that go on but truth
to tell the comics can be really tough
to follow it sometimes so i wouldn't be
surprised if you were just kind of like
i mean this video is kind of tough to
follow yeah because the comics are kind
of hard to follow things jump back and
forth it's done really really janky the
artwork is a little rough so it can be
kind of hard to follow as well they're
not bad they're really entertaining and
they're really fun it's just the
chronology can be a little difficult to
follow so with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end thank
you all for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace
you